SENATOR, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Ed: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SIGNALING HE IS OPEN TO EASING
FEDERAL GUIDELINES URGING
AMERICANS NOW TO LIMIT SOCIAL
CONTACT AND LARGELY STAY HOME.
WHAT COULD THE MEDICAL FALLOUT
BE.
DEAN OF THE NATIONAL SCHOOL OF
TROPICAL MEDICINE AND
MICROBIOLOGY AT BAYLOR COLLEGE
OF MEDICINE AND A FREQUENT
GUEST FOR US AND JOINS US ON
THE PHONE.
DOCTOR, GOOD MORNING.
TALK ABOUT THE BALANCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO MEET RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF GETTING THIS
ECONOMY GOING AGAIN BUT DOING
IT IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT SPIKE
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS.
>> YEAH, I MEAN THE PRESIDENT
IS IN A TIGHT SPOT.
HE IS DEALING WITH SOMETHING
THAT’S UNPRECEDENTED.
HERE IS THE SITUATION.
THE REASON WE ARE DOING THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO AVOID HUGE NUMBER
OF PATIENTS IN ANY PARTICULAR
CITY THAT IS BEING AFFECTED
FROM COMING INTO THE HOSPITAL
AT ONCE.
THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
NEW YORK CITY RIGHT NOW.
HOSPITALS ARE BEING OVERWHELMED
BY COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS AND
YOU HAVE HEALTHCARE WORKERS
GETTING SICK AT THE SAME TIME.
SO IT IS VERY EASY FOR A GROUP
OF HOSPITALS TO GET COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CAN’T TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS.
BY SOCIAL DISTANCING YOU SORT
OF SPREAD THAT OUT OVER TIME.
AND MAKE IT MANAGEABLE.
I -- I UNDERSTAND WHY THE
PRESIDENTS IS FRUSTRATED AND A
LOT OF AMERICANS ARE FRUSTRATED
AND WANT TO RESTART THE ECONOMY
AND HE IS DOING A LOT OF THINGS
AT THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL.
HE IS PRESSING HARD ON ALL
THOSE FRONTS.
MY TAKE ON IT IS THIS.
WE’RE JUST SEEING NOW WHAT THE
FULL IMPACT OF THE EPIDEMIC
LOOKS LIKE IN NEW YORK CITY.
LET’S LET IT PLAY OUT.
LET’S SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN
A FEW MORE WEEKS.
AND WHAT WE REALLY WITNESS WHEN
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS GET
OVERWHELMED AND LET’S GET THE
VICTORY UNDER OUR BELT IN TERMS
OF CONTROLLING IT.
THEN WE CAN REASSESS AND SAY
OKAY, HOW DID THAT GO?
WHAT WENT RIGHT AND WHAT WENT
WRONG AND THEN MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER WE WANT TO RELAX SOME
OF THE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
DON’T DO IT NOW.
>> Ed: HERE IS THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT THE
BALANCE AND HOW DIFFERENT AREAS
OF THE COUNTRY HAVE DIFFERENT
RATES OF PEOPLE BEING EXPOSED
TO CORONAVIRUS.
WATCH.
>> President Trump: YOU HAVE
AREAWHICH ARE TROUBLING AND
WE’LL BE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR, MAYOR AND EVERYBODY
ELSE ON THOSE SPOTS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME AT A
CERTAIN POINT WE HAVE TO GET
OPEN AND WE HAVE TO BE -- TO
GET MOVING.
WE DON’T WANT TO LOSE THESE
COMPANIES OR WORKERS.
>> Ed: ON TOP OF THAT DR. BURKS
AT THE SAME NEWS CONFERENCE
SAID THE BEST ESTIMATE RIGHT
NOW OF THE MORTALITY RATE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES IS .7 OR
.8%.
LESS THAN 1%.
EVERY LIFE MATTERS BUT WHEN THE
MORTALITY RATE IS THAT LOW WHAT
WOULD BE YOUR ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT IF, SAY, HE IS TRYING
TO MAKE THIS DECISION THIS
COMING WEEKEND AHEAD OF THE
EXPIRATION OF THE 15 DAYS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD?
>> SO WHAT I WOULD TELL THE
PRESIDENT AND SAY MR.
PRESIDENT, THE MORTALITY RATE
MAY SOUND LIKE A ROW RATE.
IT IS FIVE OR SIX TIMES HIGHER
THAN INFLUENZA.
IT IS NOT JUST OLDER
INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE -- WE’RE SEEING
ACCORDING TO THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL A THIRD OF THE
PATIENTS WHO ARE HOSPITALIZED
UNDER THE AGE OF 40 OR 44.
EVEN THOUGH THEY AREN’T
NECESSARILY DYING, THEIR LIVES
ARE BEING SAVED BECAUSE THEY
ARE IN ICUs BEING TAKEN CARE OF.
THE RISK -- LIKE ITALY NOW, YOU
HAVE SO MANY PATIENTS IN ICUs
THEY CAN’T TAKE CARE OF THEM
ALL AND HIGH MORTALITY.
I WOULD SAY LOOK, LET’S GET ONE
PUBLIC HEALTH VICTORY UNDER OUR
BELT HERE IN TERMS OF WHAT’S
GOING ON IN NEW YORK, MAYBE
WE’RE LOOKING AT ANOTHER MONTH.
AND THEN REASSESS.
AND I AGREE WE CAN’T STOP OUR
ECONOMY FOREVER OR EVEN FOR TWO
YEARS, BUT I THINK IF YOU DO IT
NOW, WHILE THE NUMBERS ARE
STILL STEEPLY CLIMBING IN NEW
YORK, REMEMBER NOW WE’RE SEEING
A NEW EPIDEMIC COMING UP IN NEW
ORLEANS.
WE DON’T FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW
THE EPIDEMIC WILL PLAY OUT.
A BRAND-NEW VIRUS AND GIVE IT A
NEW MONTH AND REASSESS.
>> Ed: 30 SECONDS, DOCTOR.
IN TERMS OF MORTALITY RATES,
YOU TALKED ABOUT WE HAVE TO
LEARN FROM ITALY AND SOUTH
KOREA, CHINA.
WE’VE BEEN LOOKING AT THESE
PLACES AROUND THE WORLD.
GERMANY THE MORTALITY RATE IS
.4%.
A LOT OF DOCTORS ARE LOOKING AT
THAT TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE OUTBREAK IN GERMANY GOT
IT AND SHOWED MILD SYMPTOMS.
>> THE GERMANS GOT ON TOP OF IT
EARLY AND TESTING EARLY AND THE
HOSPITALS WERE READY AND DID IT
IN A WAY WHERE HOSPITALS
WEREN’T GOING TO GET
OVERWHELMED.
THAT’S WHEN MORTALITY RATES GO
UP.
IN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WUHAN
AND CENTRAL CHINA AND OTHER
PARTS OF CHINA IT IS BECAUSE
THE HOSPITALS GOT OVERWHELMED.
CAN’T TAKE CARE OF THE PATIENTS
AND THE DOCTORS ARE GETTING
SICK AND VERSUS IN KOREA.
AND IT’S ALL ABOUT MAKING
CERTAIN A HOSPITAL CAN HANDLE
THE SURGE.
WE HAVEN’T SHOWN THAT NEW YORK
CAN DO THAT.
LET’S HOLD ON.
>> Ed: WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.